Every time you check your phone, you're
literally rewiring your brain, not
metaphorically, physically changing your
neural architecture. When you constantly
scroll through notifications, you're
training your brain to seek novelty
every few seconds. This creates
scattered attention architecture,
optimizing for distraction rather than
focus. Remember when you tried reading a
book and felt an urge to check your
phone? That's not weakness. That's your
rewired neural pathways demanding
stimulation. The good news, the same
neuroplasticity that created this
problem can solve it. Digital platforms
exploit your brain's reward system
through variable reward schedules. They
keep you scrolling with content just
interesting enough to engage, but never
truly satisfying. Start healing with a
tech sabbatical. 24 hours completely
screen-free. The first 6 hours are the
hardest. By hour 20, many experience
mental clarity they haven't felt in
years. Want to discover capabilities you
didn't know you had? Watch the full
video to learn how to make technology
your tool again instead of being its
user experience.